ladies and gentlemen brooklyn nine nine
we've been putting these up on mondays
but putting this one up on sunday
because uh batman review embargo lifts
and i think we got ourselves an early
screen so we want to meet that embargo
time
on monday anywho
we could have just uploaded it then but
in you know whatever all right you guys
leave a like if you can i'd be very much
appreciated also thanks to all who join
us on our patreon full-length watch
longs for brooklyn nine-nine over there
as well as a bunch of other shows that
we cover too and the boys at prepper
appreciate your boys helping us down
this time
rosa's wearing pink are we sure it's not
a white shirt that's just been bloodied
in a motorcycle crash well maybe it
wasn't her does she have a twin sister
if rosa had a twin she would have eaten
her in the womb
how come none of you teased her about it
it's rosa she's scary you guys are
unbelievable i once wore tie with a
splash of purple you guys called me mr
grips for two years
i forgot about mr graves if i wore a
pink shirt you'd tear me to shreds your
theater club is putting on grease and
you're playing a pink lady
oh my god
laughing if boyle was wearing a pink
shirt i get it that's hilarious what's
happening
this is the one wearing pink
and
it's gorgeous
i wish i could pull that off dream on
strawberry shortcake yeah nice try mr
grapes oh
[Music]
last night several masked men robbed a
number of check cashing locations in our
precinct they also hit several locations
in the 9-3 so this will be a joint
investigation
yes
dave majors seriously who's that his
arrest numbers are staggering his
conviction rate is magnificent he is
blotter dynamite
what's his body like on a scale from
charles to cherry sorry buddy
what
i'm that's it
sure you are
oh you're both a 10. i need someone to
partner up with them oh you believe me
sir with all due respect i'm the obvious
choice i mean look at me not in profile
you can both work the case good call sir
i was just about to start chanting vote
for jake let's do it anyway vote for
jake vote for
mr grapes please toad chartreuse for the
last time please limit your alerts to
roygbiv
gary shaw is here gary shaw has
attempted to pry me away from the nypd
for eight years i know just what i'll
say
never is not just a crater on mars of
course it is a crater on mars that's
hilarious it's not meant to be funny
boyle it's meant to be devastating
mr shaw never is not just a crater on
mars
of course it is a crater of mars well
actually i'm not here for you a member
of your squad reached out to me michael
mcdonald director this episode yeah
power love what guys terry called him
he's shaking terry's hand now i'm just
describing everything that's happening
what the hell is going on i do not know
captain hulk doesn't know
how could you terry
jake he's a highly decorated detective
he's not going to be impressed by your
sunglass choreography he's going to be
too distracted by my notebook flip hey
you must be the nine-nine oh dang
peralta this is santiago garrett
dillahunt
what do we have here you mean here in my
notebook
always wore these weird masks we
couldn't figure out where he bought him
turns out he was making his own masks
from human skin
no
that is so awesome
really amy for whom sounds to me like
those face masks where once somebody's
face
faces that's true peralta i think about
that every day you and me both
good call good call
[Laughter]
i still have eight sunglass moves locked
and loaded make that
9.
[Music]
oh no how was lunch
it was good i had the t-bone i don't
give a crap about the food just email me
about that later
you want free stuff here you go all
right you can have anything you want
from amy's desk gary made me an offer
[ __ ] a serious pay raise my own office
with walls did you tell him terry
doesn't love walls no
terry loves walls
oh
look i have another kid on the way do
you know how much diapers cost yes
live your best life
here's your [ __ ]
yikes look at all these baby masks looks
like someone's due for a spanking from
papa law nice huh uh-huh run to lot
three weeks ago and dumped here
yesterday
talk about a curbside drop-off
you're working a case here amy it's not
showtime at the apollo
hey listen i'm a member of this
invite-only speakeasy called the
keychain wanna go get a drink there
later i'd ask gamey also but i can only
bring one guess if she's busy tonight
anyway taxes are due in eight months
that's what they would do two weeks ago
well that is a horrible surprise
oh my god this guy's a bad dude or
something huh it's gonna be like
training day
milo makes you drink he knows you'll
love and then you love it orange soda
chaser ah well to the first of many
hangs yeah totally what's the bag amy
what's the deal with santiago amy oh my
god he wants to do her no
what's going on with you two you know
are you together ow
now
cool
no
you're gonna ask out amy when the case
ends
oh
yeah that's a sipping whiskey
so it is
i've been there buddy
grapes all this purple over here you
majors have too much fun last night dad
look
here
okay it's a private bar not a haunted
motel
turns out he didn't want to be best bros
at all he just wanted to know if i was
cool with him asking amy out when the
case ended just so you still like her
all right fine i still like her
i'm thinking about asking her out for
the last couple of weeks but it's hard
there's so much build up now you know
not really i don't ask people out i just
tell them where we're going
i should told him to back off i can't go
around telling guys not to ask amy out
because i like her and i'm too dumb to
do anything about it i can't make a
woman's choice for her i stand with
wendy did i do that right no
[Laughter]
i think you know what you got to do ask
her out before the case ends right i
just want to be extra clear the stakes
are through the roof for me on this one
we are throwing terry a please stay
party my vision is a frozen yogurt
machine operated by pam greer yes
yes
you have to put gina in touch with pam
grier no
yeah yeah do it you're upset that terry
would even consider leaving the
nine-nine
i'd expect this pettiness from a
spineless amoeba like charles but not
you
come on charles yep
yep
carry on oliver so we swabbed the whole
van we didn't find anything no hairs no
fibers no semen and a central van's
usually a freaking jackson pollock all
right oh no i almost feel weird saying
this but
i wanted to ask you wow those pictures
are not helping oh my god
they're really gonna have to regrout oh
uh
i wanna talk to you about something else
right now more specifically guys
dispatch just called great dave's here
now the check cashing baby's just struck
on flatbush we got to go lead the way
what did you want to tell me captain
holt sent a very important text oh
[Music]
ugh
what's that smell
pam grier a little homemade honey yogurt
infused with lavender and love
this isn't some weird breast milk or
something is it boiled i mean
technically it's from a sheep's breast
you hate looking at pictures of my twins
you said since they were identical i
didn't need to take photos of both
this is your weird way of trying to make
me stay at the nine-nine well i am
loving it oh
digitize all your case files from 1995
to 1999 inclusive by tomorrow at 9am uh
i was gonna have a cup of coffee so that
i could stay up and uh
kiss i suggest putting that caffeine
towards something more productive than
kissing
what are you doing making sure jeff's
case files are digitized by tomorrow at
9 00 a.m i thought i was perfectly clear
uh
oh no
despite what i've been saying for years
that ass just might quit
oh
there's no rhyme or reason to the
locations they hit this place was so
well guarded i mean why not hit the one
down the street that just has an old man
it just seems so random
yeah
it's like
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go grab some coffee great
stretch it out
here look the trash cans the van
jumpsuit they all say johnny's
janitorial not random they cased each
location as cleaners that's why the van
was so spotless hey what'd i miss jake
just solved the case holy crap that's
awesome
tons of paperwork and a case is never
truly done until the trial is complete
and a sentence is served jake just
celebrate
okay
wow
you don't know for sure yet though yeah
it's too late has she done the double
tuck yet when amy really likes a guy she
gets nervous and tucks her hair behind
both ears at the same time
i can never unsee that but no she's i
don't want to unsee that we did the rest
of the files for you seriously
tonight i'm gonna fall asleep in a real
movie theater
we've got each other's back damn right
charles nothing is happening on that
phone
sir these guys already digitized all my
files for me well that's not your job
and jefferson you can stay here and
digitize 2000 through 2005 inclusive i
expect it done by the morning if i
worked at copperhead i'd be home by now
swimming in a pool of gold coins like my
boy scrooge mcduck
oh that's true
they change the password password
tropical mm-hmm that's an old password
changes every night ask milo the
bartender all right he knows me i don't
know no milo the barton also changed
their names every night
this place is so cool
[Laughter]
come on strangers
show me your lips
there you go popcorn
park park
leave your phone there record
[Music]
[Music]
did she double tuck bullseye
oh no no it's a double duck you wouldn't
kick out hopeless romantic who's only
here in the name of love would you no no
i declined the offer eat it gary i gave
him back all his swag
except for the puffy vest which i uh
lost
[Music]
oh yeah
so you're done trying to push him out
yoko he's the reason i'm staying i don't
know what you're talking about you're an
adult and you came to your own decision
look at me i can't keep a straight face
ah he reflected all his work
yeah yeah
thank you captain look at you
you're like the wise old owl from this
lollipop commercial a one or two who
so had to go with santiago actually she
wasn't into it never been turned down
before someone expected
and why did she double talk how come she
turned him down and do you think it has
something to do with me rosa what is she
thinking jake yeah i should ask her
myself no no apparently he thought it
was a date right and you were not into
that because he's so muscular and in
command of his finances after everything
that happened with teddy and all the
cops i know who go out and break up and
they don't have to work together it's
just too messy
i don't take cops
hey i got an email in the commissioner's
office better case what'd they say
oh
no double tuck double talk
double talk all the time she likes them
both
nip tuck nip tuck ryan murphy woo
all right john what personal problem are
we solving today no hey uh you know
gotta be more assertive how does this
episode link to our lives gotta be more
assertive yeah john you suck at being
assertive i do let me belittle you for
10 minutes and i'll eventually open the
door for you
[Laughter]
that's how we do it expect nothing less
in fact i would panic if anything else
were to happen
anything out of that ordinary
yeah man god put yourself out there you
know gotta not shy away from sharing
your feels especially when there's
competition
just to deal with it
uh
i i mean nowadays i don't go out so no
but i mean back in the day i felt like i
would yeah deal with competition sure or
just uh i don't know more being in the
uh peralta shoes of like i don't know i
don't even know what to say i'm trying
to figure out like the right way to do
it but there's never the right time to
say something you know it's i'm usually
that peralta
uh you know in need of the
the extra urge to be like i'm going to
the speakeasy i'm doing the knock i'm
going to go cause a scene
gonna go shoot my not taking away my
shot you know
they weren't playing basketball they
weren't
playing
but
but how many basketball practices have
had a hamilton based you know interlude
i bet a lot of them have
been a lot of basketball practice has
some you know hamilton songs playing in
the background
yeah venn diagram that exists
yeah man i think my my thing is
sometimes
not as much as i used to
i think a lot of what jake goes through
is what i went through when i was
younger and that's what makes it so
funny to me
because i
think this is like stuff of like a
teenager yeah
oh i've been there or like an early a
younger adult i would say yes of like
you're around an alpha and you try to
like measure up to him
yeah try to distinguish yourself somehow
while like yeah you try to play to them
to gain their favor and also play off
them as if you're just cool to the
people around yeah that was my that was
probably my main that was a big problem
of mine is a lot of like
succumbing to what i perceived as status
yeah or
cool yeah yeah and now so i would try to
match up or get approval yeah now i'm
like very much recent with that attitude
i'm just like i don't know i'm not
dealing with you
a time of energy of mine for this i'm
not putting up with this like false
bravado anymore um but no that's what i
liked about the way the detective majors
played it like he he had a confidence
and a swag about him but he wasn't like
a
like a like a
cocky douchebag about it yeah no it's
the opposite he's like he's throwing
every line away he's like yeah you know
it's just what i do every single day you
know whatever this makes him so cool i
thought he was playing well like i
thought they were the way they were
setting him up was expecting
one of those i thought i was gonna be
like some famous guest star who's really
cocky is what i thought i thought it was
gonna be yeah i thought it was gonna be
a famous comedian yeah it was gonna be a
player that's remarkably straight for
the most part which which i love when
garrett dillahunt pops up in more
comedic things because that guy i feel
like is an underrated actor and he's got
like this ability like he's not
so well known that he
can't like i i like that he pops up in
places like this where you might not
expect and then you know other things
that are more you know like big
hollywood sci-fi movie or something like
that you know i feel like he's got a fun
range
um
he's not the first actor that comes to a
lot of people's minds but he always
leaves an impression
seeing american
i think he is
i have no idea anymore i just heard an
interview with the guy who plays
vigilante and i was like what you're
british what's going on yeah i heard an
interview with a guy who plays nate on
euphoria and i was like
you're not american always the guys with
distinct american voices
oh [ __ ] no wonder you made our accent
sound cooler yeah it must not be from
here um yeah so i i thought that was a
neat storyline and
the way they are flirting the line with
amy and peralta
this push and pull game man just admit
it just admit it yeah
just kind of come together and put your
diffs aside
so being self-conscious the both of you
that was a clever reveal of what they
did with uh
with sec with the whole with terry and
holt yeah yeah because i was like is he
acting out like pushing him away because
i was really on that side of the thing
it was until it was until terry said
something like i only realized it like
moments before it yeah that was revealed
like
ah
he's gonna reflect yeah yeah because i
was expecting there to be like some kind
of uh like okay like holt will come back
around and apologize yeah like that and
yeah i liked that choice a lot that was
a nice uh payoff that was a really good
mislead it was like a clever mislead
because it's right in front of you and
then you're like gosh that's why i was
so upset when when terry didn't do it
himself yeah exactly and i love that
tension that that creates of like oh
they're helping out and it seems like
what they're doing is is leading to the
outcome we all want but actually it's
not or or it potentially might not be
well he has to choose to stay there
because you know terrorists jesus say
they're not to you know
gina and um boyle are not going to just
be kissing his ass the whole time and
being his freaking servants
you know yeah he's choosing to stay he's
going to lose that privilege so
yeah he had to draw that conclusion in
itself
it's hard to let people go it is
it's tough man
but i'm willing to do it
dude what you got to do
oh later
it's been nice knowing you cutting the
cord right here on camera oh good you
saw hey that's a then people can react
to it
yeah
you ever been to a speakeasy
ah
i want to say yes
i'm sure i know you have right you've
been to been to one or two i've been to
one speed yes yes i have now i remember
i've been to one speakeasy but uh
yeah that was for i was probably a
minute ago actually part of something
like two years ago sometimes sometime
last year uh there was like
one of the one of the places uh in like
noho opened back up as as like
quarantine speak easy where it was like
okay you bring your vax card you'll get
a special like card that says like that
we checked you out and you can come into
the bar
and it's like super limited capacity
but that's different you know that's
that's not as cool
you still feel exclusive but it's
different than like
hey i got the password you know the
speakeasy i went to was uh
downtown la or someone's event
someone's like has had a little
celebration and then uh
yeah it was it was neat like the way you
you go in there and you know it's like
some of those things where you walk into
a spot and it looks like it's nothing
and like you get mugged there and then
you go into a fall and yeah they open
this like [ __ ] library section and
they're like oh yeah they're like a huge
[ __ ] secret bart he was like matt it
was massive
and uh that was really cool that's like
a burlesque dancer towards the end too
oh fun nice that would be a fun
hollywood pub crawl is to go find all
the places where you have to walk in
through like a refrigerator or a
bookcase or some kind of trap door
that would be the best this is funny
because a lot of them aren't that
secretive no
it's because you have yelp now
well and the secrecy becomes the gimmick
it becomes like the advertisement it's
really the point it's just the entrance
yeah it's it's the entering of that
makes it exciting come to the cool door
got a cool door
that's the way it is it's so like the
internet makes it impossible to hide
most of them you never expected to enter
the bar through the trunk of a car
but
it would be neat to uh
it would be cool to actually um
yeah i remember actually when i did go
speak easy that that staircase was
really tight um yeah yeah
but the but it would be cool to go to
one where it is like a exclusive club
member yeah however you need to be
brought into one of those and then the
magic cast ooh there you go or club
33 or whatever it is at disneyland the
the bar restaurant that's like in the
new orleans place
it's like the legendary like only the
specials
you got to know somebody deep within
disney to go
yeah i always think it's all just okay
it's i mean
unless that thing is unless that kind of
place is just absolutely your jam i feel
like you get inside and you're like yeah
it's a room with drinks
like any other
i've really realized in the past two
years just how much of a simpleton i've
become
super
simple i'm i am no frills i am a simple
god
i'm sure
i'm like i like to go to bed and even
though i never get to sleep but i like
to go to bed i like to watch tv
yeah i prefer
you know smaller hangouts versus big
hangouts okay so my speakeasy
20 person capacity
instead of chairs and booths there's
gonna be bunk beds with tvs
so you can just climb in relax have a
drink watch tv yes and everyone will
have headphones it'll be like one of
those discos where you just listen to
your headphones
and uh yeah then you could just hang out
outside of the home drink and watch tv
in bed we went to see a movie once it
was star trek two i believe and uh
we had the there's rather con that one
and we had they went to that theater
where they had the headphones oh the
arena and the rooftop what was so stupid
about it was people were like
beautiful that's the look is the look
there uh
yeah or if you need sunglasses they
should make a kind of headphones that
instead of a headband it just has
sunglasses in the front
so that you can recycle you can kill two
birds yeah
have them x-men branded officially
but the thing with the headphones at
that one
theater was like people thought they're
wearing headphones so whoever's not
watching the movie you can just talk
obnoxiously loud oh god yeah
no i can't hear you pretty clear man
these aren't that noise can't you guys
we should all still be paying somewhat
of attention
yeah but it would be cool to go to more
theaters that do that mm-hmm yeah all
right guys well thanks for being here
say hi to your mother for me uncharted
2.
and uh we'll catch you guys uh soon
but now before we do the pictures shout
outs
alex b were fever faster master t i have
an affinity for pseudonymous entity
olivia of rivia del gai whimsically
indifferently sane levitt posted on
reddit odell lauren always scoring with
an american or african horse that's
coarse simply faded never jaded peter
pacheco in slow mo
joanna texarkana saint louis
rogue cree will flee the country solid
jokes 94.
justin martin sharper than clint barton
rosie beatty duel of the fadey colin
would you quit stalin philip j smith jr
here to tune your piano jen pooping into
chicken hen smith melanie leblanc has
got the funk natalie doran scoring with
jamie dornan chase gardner better faster
stronger eva drastic over soaring like a
supernova and of course jason dolan josh
brolin
love you all
glad to see you here for another month
of
wild and whimsical name warpings on you
guys names
stick around for more brilliant gold
comedy to come next month
thanks guys love you
thank you guys
[Music]